feet under you
elbow tight
do arm wrestling with her get to her
center
[Music]
your head you're projecting ahead of her
just don't do anything just keep your
grip that's all you have to do it's
ahead of you
you see just keep your grip keep your
grip
i'm naming the head i'm going here
going like this bring your elbow up when
you see viable
it's out and then you're ahead of the
person
on the move
and i'll show you what you can do with
this
don't go don't go don't go what'd you
feel uh
yeah you feel a wrist locked you see i'm
doing this out here look at the
difference
okay
not a head
why do you think you're going ahead
i'm looking at the second thing no
why don't you go ahead
i'll show you hi
push into my center
push into my center it's very heavy in
heart
go in front of me
with your energy hi
push
aim into my center hi what do you feel
heavy heart heavy and hard now aim over
here in front of my spine in front of my
spine what do you feel nothing it's
wider isn't it do you think what will
wash your body now go push push
look at you push in front of me
do you see so why do you think you're
going in front of yourself it's
it's easier it's easier okay
let's ask them first question why is it
harder
to go
to the center
that's the real question
do you understand everyone wants to go
well because you're
not pushing the weight i was never
pushing the way hi do you understand
so you know my arm is sharing my arms
but my arm is
okay so it's not true that it's a
dichotomy between
heavy and light and strong and weak
that's not true
it's how i'm doing
what i'm doing that makes one harder and
one easier
do you understand so
if we watch what you're doing
and you're trying to move my you're just
you're just pushing into me right now
we're just doing that not on the
technique yet you're pushing into me
push
what do you where do you feel the
tension go go do it where do you feel it
right here yes okay
here
pretty sure push hard stand up if you
want stand up and push
okay
oh now if i do it like you you're going
to feel the tension
you're going to feel the attention see
so it's how i'm doing it
not what i'm doing okay and because of
how i'm doing it the other one i choose
because i can't do the first one is too
hard
because of how i'm doing okay
so it's an internal thing your weight
comes in boom hits goes through my
center hits the ground comes back up
okay
comes in
boom
in
not
even you are heavy on me for that like
that's not marshall to to take that long
to move your body is not martial you're
gonna do something else in the middle
okay so it's how you're doing
and you can't keep doing it like this
because you're gonna keep going like
that
okay
you have to figure it out
it's no different than if we're doing
this simple
cochlear yoke
i'm just doing the same
[Music]
because the angle where you go in front
is not martial either even though it's
easier
that's wrong
because the real problem is why is the
one to the center harder
and that's the problem you have to
address
okay think trap no no no no keep going
there's a trap there there's a trapping
mechanics there
so right right here wait
so do i run across my body on a trap
okay so the trap has tapping in on the
inside of my outer rim can't happen to
the outside and i don't want to expose
the left side of my ribs and i don't
want to use my left deltoid
okay coming over from the side
better
now find the harmony of the trap
it's not it's not one two it's one
[Music]
better
and now add the elbow to the harmony so
i i do the trap and i'm in the elbow i
do the trap i'm in the elbow whoa
oh see that pause in there okay
okay stop
i'm not gonna go
one
you see this is doing nothing
okay
my hands are dynamic
they're not ever stopping and they
synchronize with each other so as much
as this hand is moving towards the wrist
this hand is moving towards the other
hand do you understand okay i said the
same here and it waits and then i grab
it
everything's moving tell me
watch
as much as this hand is moving towards
this wrist my body is moving out there
and i'm doing my circle
[Music]
trap
goes to the elbow is the trap
on the
elbows to the elbow
inches with the
grab hand insert with the ground
yeah compromise with your brick
so don't put your thumb inside
don't try to capture this on this way
big hands you can't do that i'll use
this this thumb knuckle this thumb
knuckle
on this thumb knuckle down here
push pinky down at the bottom boom and
keep your palm with no space
the more you squeeze your fingers the
more your
center of your hand cuts then less space
there you have it here
you see all right
well that's where i go okay why do i get
there it's already there
look
that's where i put it i put that knuckle
right there
i don't use it yet
here's where it starts to go
same place
oh fingers toward your head
making a hat put it right there it's in
place don't use it though wait until the
pinky gets in place
just lay it there don't use it yet
because my pinky can't get in there if i
do this i'm exposing just put it right
in there
when it turns over i'm bringing your
hand into my pinky there it is now i can
use the thumb
won't
put it in place don't use it
make sure you're ahead okay